so here's the paradox of pre-katrina New
Orleans for its 10 million pie-eyed
vacationers who trolled the sticky
streets of the French Quarter year after
year the city was a pulsating
profit-making Pleasure Dome for a few
bucks the city would happily serve up
just about anything you could scarf down
yet right across the Mississippi River
the Orleans Parish School Board was
making the Department of Motor Vehicles
look like a model of efficiency a toxic
swamp of fraudin and competence the
school board was tilting on the edge of
bankruptcy when Katrina wiped out much
of the city taking a bureaucracy with it
school choice swept in as a replacement
and nine years later test scores and
graduation rates are on the rise minus
the red tape and the teachers union
public education is actually looking
pretty sunny in the Big Easy but can it
really last maybe a school board that
predates the Civil War doesn't just blow
away in a gust of wind could the old
bureaucracy really emerged from the dark
swamp of inefficiency from which it sank
reasontv went to New Orleans to find out
people like autonomy in the abstract but
they get real nervous about it if any
one of a hundred or a thousand schools
to something goofy there's always a
natural temptation to say well we're for
autonomy but let's have a rule that
doesn't let you do X and the point that
my McShane and I made in this USA
today's story is that the natural
temptation to say we're for autonomy so
long as schools don't do x over time
tends to lend itself to one new rule
being stacked upon one new regulation
and over the course of years the idea
that charter schools can make curricular
and instructional and program decisions
as they see fit tends to become more and
more attenuated at the end of the day if
you keep up long enough you wind up with
charter schools that don't necessarily
look any different than the traditional
district schools that they were supposed
to challenge what we're trying to figure
out new orleans and we're the first city
to ever have to tackle these questions
so what's the tension between regulation
autonomy and so we've totally
decentralized educational programming
educators on the ground get to make
decisions about what they think is best
for kids and we've totally decentralized
choice family is going to pick what
schools are right for them over the past
four to five years we've put in a bunch
of regulations to help ensure that when
you're going to choice we also have
equity so we have a centralized
enrollment system we have a centralized
expulsion system charter schools cannot
just kick kids out this is this is how
we want with the regulatory cream the
idea that you can distinguish choice
from equity I think is a nifty
rhetorical trick but I'm not sure it's
as simple as those folks you talk to
would like it to be
although the size and scope of New
Orleans educational bureaucracy is a
small fraction of what it used to be the
complex structure of public school
governance remains a serious obstacle to
continued reform the challenge of
navigating the city's tangled web of
authorities while educating the city's
43,000 students is taken on by dedicated
principles like Julie louse of the
Harriet Tubman charter school in Algiers
well I mean it's very similar to a lot
of other schools Harriet Tubman was a
failing school in 2011 within two years
we moved it from failing to a see the
autonomy is the number one reason why I
feel like I can make a difference here
right so I have autonomy over my staff
and my curriculum and my program my
schedule in a day and all that kind of
stuff if I didn't have that I wouldn't
be able to do anything the balance
between regulation and autonomy came to
a head over the issue of student
discipline until last year New Orleans
charter schools set their own policies
for disciplining unruly students but
when a few schools were found to have
unusually high rates of expulsion 'he's
parents got angry parents teens and
activists speak out against what they
call oppressive conditions at the
charter schools complaints range from
mass suspensions they were just called
and said we're suspending him and we're
going to send him home on a public RTA
and give him a bus token the state was
quick to intervene taking control of all
student disciplinary procedures in New
Orleans but later that year Louisiana's
own state investigation of school
expulsion painted a very different
picture New Orleans has followed the
national trend in every year they've
been measured charter schools have lower
rates of expelling students than
traditional public schools elsewhere in
the state and by some measures
explosions actually increased after the
state took over the process of
disciplining students but if parents are
unhappy with their school's expulsion
policy why are they protesting in the
streets why don't they just exercise
their right to school choice and
transfer their child to another school
I've been trying to get on another
school to pull out of here that's hard
because it's not so far in the school
year that I can't just pull out and put
us somewhere else I wish I could because
a new regulation enacted last year
prevents students from transferring
to another school after six weeks into
the semester so we used to have a system
where any day in the school year as
school a child could transfer out and
what we found is that led to higher
mobility rates and you could also get
into tip first half of a kid gets a
detention and then they pull out of the
school and that can be destabilizing
towards the system of schools believe me
I there have been parents who've been in
my school who really want to switch
after six weeks and I want to support
them because they are so unhappy the
mid-year switches are not only stressful
for kids and families but they're
stressful for schools to get that many
kids in the middle of the year coming
from other schools at some point we have
to shut the enrollment process down and
say okay we're done with their moment
for the year now the next chance is next
year that does take away from some of
our autonomy but I think in the long run
it's better for kids and for schools
it's something we have to be very
careful of a system like this could be
undermined by a death by a thousand
regulatory cuts what makes me optimistic
that that won't happen is first I think
the political class is starting to
understand why this system works and I
hope that that's getting ingrained in
the DNA of who we are as a city second
is you have a pretty big constituency at
this point that I hope will fight for
their rights part of the challenge is
how do you say look these are reasonable
regulations but we don't want to go any
further than this what where do we stake
out the no further than this and I think
this is where the charter community has
not done as good a job as it as it
should in New Orleans or anywhere else
for anybody that's criticizing the
public school system and New Orleans by
saying oh you guys think you know
everything we don't we're working hard
at it in an imperfect system but I am
proud of where we are I mean
thirty-three percent of the city passed
tested basic levels in 2004 and now it's
67 just that growth has never been seen
in the history of our country before
we're going to be the first mostly black
city to outperform it's mostly white
state in the history of this country so
I think there's something significant
about to what's happening here and we're
not yet there we're not yet perfect we
aren't in a school system yet but I
think we're on the way